there was a death at the comedy store
this week uh
a man died
a man died and a man died
you know a man died and
and he died
he died and the man named jeff
and jeff was a pianist at the comedy
store and he was probably
i mean he was human furniture really he
was a
he was like a water fountain of that
place
and i meant that because he would really
he would he kind of spit a lot when he
talked but also because he was a fixture
you know he was he was just a beloved
man he was the pianist
and when you brought up on stage when he
broke when you came up on stage he would
play you up
and you know as comedians we're so much
in our head we're in our own ego a lot
of times so once they call your name
it's just
you feel your body walking up there and
then you feel your body grabbing the mic
i would always say you guys give it up
for jeff over here
you know he's blind i would say
and um and he wasn't blind you know
but he would pretend he was blind you
know he was just kind of blind out
and uh and he did it every time every
time i got on stage there it was just
this little moment that he and i had
and um and i know that sounds crazy but
it was just
this thing that was a constant
and we would have some nice chats you
know he would always tell me nice things
you know hey man this thing this bit
you're doing is really
it's good you're doing a good job
just keep doing what you're doing
nobody's doing
what you're doing and he made me feel
hopeful
you know he gave me a lot of hope
and he also gave me he gave me a rape
whistle also
but um
but yeah he died you know he died
and uh
and he died and he died and um
he died like three four days ago
and it really breaks my heart man
because part of me wonders
did he die from
just the separation you know i think he
was 60 or 70 years old he might have
been 75 years old
and part of me wonders how much of a man
how much can a man's
you know with no connection
like how many more people are we losing
from code because of
disconnection
and i don't know if we'll know the
repercussions of some of that
you know especially a lot of people that
struggle with addiction and struggle
with
um those sorts of you know in all types
of addiction you know it's like
when we isolate it can be really not
good
and so i wonder how many
how many people just stuck in their own
little worlds without some reflection in
the universe to let them know that
they're good or they're okay
you know as much as jeff played us on
his keys and brought us up there every
night
uh we everybody looked over at him and
smiled
everybody acknowledged him he'd go blow
a joint you know
he was gassed up so on that dude he
missed half of his work
you'd get off stage and and be ready to
bring up the next person he went even
there
he literally had to work like 12
one minute spots throughout the night
and he would probably make about eight
of them
um
but it was just he came there and he
just everybody loved him he was this
weird like you know sometimes he throw
one of those little rubber balls and it
just goes
it just goes and it's bouncing off the
nest this and it's bouncing and he was
like that he just touched everybody
[Music]
um
and and he had crazy stories man he he
he got aids bro he got aids and he
you know and i would even joke from
stage you know jeff right here y'all
give it up for jeffy's terminally ill
you know and uh
and he got aids man and i think that's
brave as hell people say you know
you know say this and that about aids
but i think that's that's brave as hell
man and um
he has a great episode with brian
scalaro that is out and he had recorded
it five days before his death and
you can go listen to that we'll put the
link as that as that as well in
in below
and man he you know
and he just he used to tell me about
being young and being in a place called
provincetown and it was
real gay you know real like kind of gay
hitmen
dude come up and just stab you six or
seven times with that peter bruh
with that waner that kind of place you
know
you're trying to buy a soda and they
give you half a cup of cop
you know when he said he got taken
advantage some and
and then he ended up out in los angeles
and uh
and he thought his life was gonna end
but his life really began when he got
out there
um and i didn't really know that i would
care as much
not to say that mean that something you
just don't know when some people leave
the earth how much it's going to hit you
and
it just you know it didn't
it just made me realize how different
things are gonna be and how much
a lot of people might be struggling
[Music]
um
you know and i didn't i didn't ever know
you know he really had i mean i just for
him to wake up and be positive every day
and having gay aids man
and it just be to show up every day
you know and uh
and that's you know
and that's really the that blood ghost
baby aids
and um
yeah i just want to say thank you jeff
man you know we love you bro
and you were nice and you were warm and
you were kind and you didn't ever be
wild or try to [ __ ] or do anything wild
like that you just
you know you gave homestead to people
that needed it
um
and i i felt like you would have shared
with anybody you would have shared your
time and i wish i had spent more time
with you brother
you know i wish i had gotten to know you
a little bit better man uh
you know and we love you jeff jeff scott
i want to let you know that
oh man um yeah sorry i didn't mean to
get off like that but
uh you know life is just this
it's like
life is just like this
life's like this it's like a like an
outfit or a costume or a coat
and the second i start to kind of feel
like i know what it feels like
it it turns into like a
just a different
and i can never
i can never wear it right i can never
know how i look in it i can never
i can never know if it fits really it's
just brief moments of know of
of life feeling tailored um
before it completely readjusts man and
god bless you jeff scott man and uh
yeah we love you bro you know i don't
know if you know and i don't know what
you were going through when you were at
home and you were by you know
for you know what was going on you know
and i'm sorry that uh you and i weren't
closer
but i just didn't realize how big of a
part you were in my life and of a lot of
other people's lives man
and i'm happy that i got to um cross
paths with you
on this realm brother gang hi everyone
i'm jeff scott i'm the house pianist at
the world famous comedy store on sunset
strip
here in hollywood california i play five
nights a week
and i've been there for 24 years my
first year was working with richard
pryor during his
last year so i'm pretty damn old
anyway i thought i'd play my pre-show
for you
so you can enjoy it while we're doing
this live streaming comedy show
here we go
[Music]
everybody christmas it just turned
midnight
and my costume's ready
[Music]
okay this isn't my costume
do
[Music]
foreign
and now on with the show
look instant
it's just masculinity a joke kids okay
don't get
well look it's my portable boom box
stand don't spray it what it's time for
a commercial
we gotta go again okay well i better go
otherwise the sponsors will sue us
for a spartan battery
we'll be right back
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]